- [Interviewer] All right Scott.
Scott, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Scott] Orange County, California.
- [Interviewer] Orange County,
and tell me about your family.
You grew up with both of your parents?
- [Scott] Yeah, both my parents,
they divorced when I was young,
my dad was a bit of a gambling addict,
when I was young and my
mom was an alcoholic.
- [Interviewer] Your dad
was a gambling addict?
- Addict, yeah briefly and
then he was a workaholic.
He was a lawyer, so,
and my mom was a CPA, she
owned her own CPA firm.
They both actually owned
their own firms, but...
- [Interviewer] And she was into drugs?
- She wasn't before I was born.
I think she contracted hepatitis C
through birth and then she also...
she was an alcoholic through
like most of my childhood.
So very, very detached, very not present.
- [Interviewer] So how was your childhood?
- I never went without.
It wasn't too...
I can't say I was like, I
was too disenfranchised,
but I didn't have the
attention I probably needed
and craved as a child.
- [Interviewer] Did you have siblings?
- I ended up, my mom got
married to a man named Dennis.
Probably shouldn't say names, but...
Mom got married to a man,
he was a really good stepdad,
but very, very iron
fist with him, as well.
He was a Marine Corps drill instructor.
So there's a lot of things
that come along with that.
- [Interviewer] (chuckles) Yeah.
- Yeah, and then I got a
lot of sisters out of that,
a lot of step-sisters.
I have five, no four stepsisters.
- [Interviewer] What age
were you when you left home?
- Sorry?
- [Interviewer] When you
left your parents' care,
what age were you when you left?
- I was 18, I went to go to college.
- [Interviewer] Where'd you go?
- I went to Oklahoma State.
Yeah, it was briefly, only
went there for about a year,
that's when I was introduced to heroin,
was actually on a winter
break from school,
my oldest (indistinct).
- [Interviewer] Are you
still using heroin today?
- Yes. Yeah.
And fentanyl, but predominantly heroin.
- [Interviewer] How old are you now?
- I'm 29.
- [Interviewer] What do
you do for money now?
- Re-acquisition of goods.
Well, actually re-appropriation of goods.
- [Interviewer] Understood.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What
do you spend on heroin?
- Gosh, say from $100 to $200.
- [Interviewer] A day?
- A day.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
And the fentanyl, you...
- Well, I try not to.
I do it when I'm sick or when
I can't get anything else.
- [Interviewer] What's
the difference, basically?
- Fentanyl is a lot more dangerous.
I noticed that it changes
people pretty drastically
like people, anybody that's
a daily user of fentanyl
will change. Absolutely.
The core parts of the
personality, core parts
of their moral compass
will change as well.
And I have noticed, it's not
it's not a matter of if,
it's a matter of when.
- [Interviewer] And what
kind of changes do you see?
- A shadiness factor.
Like people that weren't
shady become shady
this is something I see on
a daily basis it seems like
people that weren't shady become shady
and people that are shady become shadier.
- [Interviewer] Like
what? Lying, stealing?
- Lying, stealing, and
the like, yeah, exactly.
- [Interviewer] Interesting.
And where do you stay now?
You're in a tent?
- Yeah. I mean, sometimes
I generally, I float around
I consider myself a nomad.
I try not, I mean, I have
a mattress pad and I have a blanket.
- [Interviewer] Yeah you have
a giant backpack over there.
- Yeah, yeah. I sure do.
I suppose I sold my
other backpack last night
and I dropped to that one, but yeah.
- And so you're 29, do you have
do you have kids or anything like that?
- I don't.
I don't, but yeah, no
actually I think thankfully,
no kids. (Indistinct)
but yeah, I did. I had
a couple girlfriends
and one I think actually just
jumped in front of a train
recently. It's really...
- [Interviewer] Your girlfriend
jumped in front of a train?
- Yeah, it was, we had already broken up
but she was really depressed
and she used to just,
recently got homeless
got a job at the zoo and
she was really depressed.
And I haven't heard from her in awhile
but heard something or
- [Interviewer] Where did this happen?
- The expo line. I think it was
- [Interviewer] Oh, here in LA.
- Yeah, LA.
- [Interviewer] When was that?
- It was last month. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So January.
- Yeah. After Christmas.
- [Interviewer] And do you
have mental issues as well
do you think?
- Yeah.
I have severe depression.
Thanks man.
Yeah. Oh man.
Excuse me.
Ah, yeah.
Depression, severe depression, PTSD.
Yeah. I was sexually assaulted
as a youth and, and again
since I've been out here.
- [Interviewer] I'm
sorry, as a youth what?
- I was sexually assaulted
- [Interviewer] By who?
- By a friend's parent.
- [Interviewer] How old were you?
- I was like 8.
- [Interviewer] And then you
said something else happened
when you were out here?
- Yes, I was out here
and some guy drugged me.
I was like, staying with him.
I should have known the signs,
but I was shiny and dumb.
I just said, you know?
I, I thought, here's this nice
dealer he's going to hang out
with me for a weekend.
Hang out with me for a couple of days
and feed me drugs for free. And then
he drugged me and then
I'd come to and be like
"what the fuck is happening?"
And then go back out.
And then like three days
after that, he was like
"you knew what was going
on," I was like, "I really
didn't think"
he's like, "you knew what this was all
about from the get go."
I was like, "I didn't like,
like I didn't. I wish I did
but I didn't."
So sorry I hope that was clear, but yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah this
neighborhood's treacherous.
- (chuckles) Yeah it's a mess.
I tried to stay out of
Skid Row honestly, my dad
brought me here when I was a kid
and, he drove me around and he said
"this is where you go if you're bad."
So I try to avoid this
area as being my home.
- [Interviewer] Where do
you hang out mostly then?
- I do business in MacArthur
Park, but I'm pretty much
I stay towards the West side.
- [Interviewer] That's like
the mini Skid Row over there.
- Right, exactly. It's like
Main street market skid row, yeah
- [Interviewer] It's
almost like the same thing
- Yeah, exactly.
But I, I stay, I try to
say the West Side, mostly
it's people seem to be a
little bit kinder out there
and you don't deal
with the same bullshit as you do out here.
- [Interviewer] Yeah it's really bad here.
- Right, right.
(chuckles) That it is.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have any plans or goals?
- Yeah.
I plan to be out of
here by the time I'm 30,
sobering up in the next
- [Interviewer] That's coming up
- 4 months, yeah.
So yeah I plan to be off
the street and probably
hopefully clean.
- [Interviewer] You
think you'll get clean?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been clean before?
- I have yeah.
- [Interviewer] How'd you do it?
- A program. I'd go to
rehabs and I've gotten bits
of sobriety and that's
what discourages me though.
That I've had these bits
of sobriety and then
I keep reverting to
this, this kind of shit.
Every time it's worse
because I've never been
homeless till this run.
- [Interviewer] Have you
ever been on medications
for depression?
- Yeah Prozac, but I never
noticed it make a difference
I'd still get these manic
episodes, manic depression
- [Interviewer] And you're
not taking anything now?
- No, presently I'm not no.
It was, it didn't seem to
be helpful at all. I was
in the hospital for six
weeks because I don't know
if you can tell but my
neck is pretty messed up
I have an internal,
epidural abscess in my neck.
At least that's what they
said I had for the six weeks
of hospital stay, and
then, then I had three days
of standing upright again.
I didn't always walk, stand like this.
- [Interviewer] Oh so the
reason your head hangs forward
is because of...?
- Yeah. It's because I have an
epidural abscess in my neck.
It returned after three days
of being out here I guess.
They wanted to do, I wanted
them to do surgically,
they opted out of doing
that for whatever reason.
He said, he said it was unsafe.
And that, that the IV of antibiotics
would definitely take care of it.
But didn't work.
- [Interviewer] Do you still
have contact with your family?
- Yeah, I haven't called my dad
and my mom in probably a couple
months. But I do call my dad
- [Interviewer] They know you're out here?
- Yeah. Yeah, they do.
Much to their chagrin
- [Interviewer] Have you ever OD'd?
- Yeah. A handful of times.
Probably, actually when I last relapsed
I OD'd twice at the sober
living I was staying at.
That was my reason for
leaving that sober living.
It wasn't very sober sober living.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- That' was my reason for
leaving that sober living,
it wasn't a very sober sober living.
- [Interviewer] Oh I see.
What do you wish was different
about your life or
childhood that might have
changed your path or where you are today?
- So much. (crying)
I meet these people out
here that had so much
worse childhoods than I
and it make feel kind
of grateful for like the
sick shit that happened to me.
- [Interviewer] All right
Scott, well, thank you so much
for coming in and good
luck with everything.
- Thank you.